saison on travaille dans un salon de
coiffure dans le département 77 et vous
dites je sais je suis différent depuis
très jeune j'ai toujours joué avec des
scies à la dînette et aux barbies ça
fait un an que je sors maquiller et six
mois que je vais dehors avec mes
périples la même question que pour louer
ce qu'il ya eu de très jeunes s'exercent
qui a eu dans un passé récent ont un peu
plus lointain un événement qui vous a
fait prendre conscience à vous aussi que
la distinction hommes femmes ça ne
marchait pas pour vous bah tout
simplement en fait si aussi enfin par
rapport à mon père j'ai pas eu l'amour
patin de plus tout le monde a entre
guillemets c'est à dire que c'est
peut-être ça qui m'a fait entre
guillemets évolué et tout simplement m'a
en fait si l'évolution décider ou pas
des générations on apprend d'autres
choses on voit d'autres choses donc
forcément ça fait évoluer la mentalité
des gens en fait simplement alors par
rapport à ce que disait virginité
l'aisne il y avait deux choses
parler d'un effacement des sexes mais
c'est parce que vous demandez est ce que
vous êtes d'accord pour que l'acte de
naissance reconnaissent un sexe puisque
l'autre ah oui totalement ça serait
mieux pour badiane
il y aura plus de choix aux enfants qui
vont battre ou tout simplement venir ou
le monde etc
il y aura plus de soi pour se
reconnaître même et pas avoir être dans
une case en fait dans la société
les mêmes questions aussi pour finir
ensuite je vais faire un tour de table
des chroniqueurs mais dans votre vie
quotidienne
est-ce que ça se passe aussi bien pour
l'instant que sur ce plateau tout le
monde vous écoutez c'est de comprendre
où est ce que vous voulez le retire des
difficultés dans les enfants font
souvent à la différence entre un nom
binaire et guerre ou transat donc c'est
de ces trois salles différentes
du coup sa grille si on s'insulte est
aussi humiliant public qui doit fermer
entre guillemets notre blues je ne sais
pas encore bah autre hymne au grand jour
par nous dit que parfois ce qui vous
insultent sont aussi les mêmes qui vous
drague confirmation en général il se
casse parce qu'ils l'avouent pas eux
mêmes qui sont entre guillemets soit
comme ou soit différent des autres en
fait juste pour son dans la masse et
entre guillemets assez lisse envers les
autres c'est très grégaire comme toutes
les personnes trans que je connais ont
déjà eu ont déjà eu ce problème là le
souci c'est qu'en fait parce qu'on
dépasse parce qu'on dépasse 2
de la norme des gens dans une certaine
mesure on va avoir tendance à être les
premières personnes qui vont être visés
par les blagues par les insultes et
malheureusement dans notre cas très
couramment les menaces et souvent les
violences le problème c'est que souvent
c'est de l'incompréhension et la
majorité des gens que j'ai rencontrés
jusqu'ici même des gens qui étaient
totalement fermé à l'idée de nos
minorités ou transidentité à la base
sont des gens par enseigner c'est pas
des gens agressifs et nécessairement ce
que c'est l'ignorance qui conduit je
pense qu'il ya vraiment des gens qui
sont ignorants mais qui n'ont pas envie
d'apprendre
mais je pense que la plupart des gens
qui ne connaissent pas ce sujet parce
qu'il ya énormément de terme difficile à
appréhender et qu'on n'ait pas beaucoup
enseigné dessus sont tout à fait ouvert
à se renseigner